good evening everyone and welcome to
this northwest area planning committee
meeting um held on it is that march 22.
my name is councillor maddie thompson
and i'm the chairman of this committee
before we commence the business of the
meeting there are a few housekeeping
issues to run through
members we're now working with the set
up has agreed at council
and most aspects are back to the
pre-covered normal however some people
will choose to wear a mask
and uh
i'll take other measures and i'll just
ask you to respect that please we are
streaming this meeting live as well as
recording and by being present in the
meeting you are giving your consent to
being recorded
when invited to speak please turn on
your microphone and speak clearly
referencing a page or paragraph number
when referring to the agenda papers
please keep your contributions as clear
and concise as possible and ensure your
micro microphones remain off when not
speaking as this is important for the
live streaming to be heard clearly
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers regarding
the different levels within the chamber
and advise that the fire exit is the
door
heights top table
members may i also draw your attention
to the members update with further
information on item five on the agenda
it is quite lengthy so if anyone would
like a minute to read it please let me
know
item two is apologies for absence please
miss bird i know we've had one uh
thank you that's apologies from
councillor
right item three is minutes it's
recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 2nd of february
found on pages 7 to 10 are approved as a
true and accurate record
may i take them as read
members please oh ok i so move do i have
a second if you're getting
right seconded by let's say council of
keys
um
and
did everyone agree
any dissent any corrections right thank
you very much
okay item four declarations of interest
i'm afraid i have to read all this
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraph six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members and members are reminded they're
also required to disclose any such
interests as soon as they become aware
should the need arise through the
meeting
any takers please counselor durham
thank you chairman and non-cunary
interest has a member of essex county
council who are statutory
consultants in relation to things like
highways etc thank you council fleming
thank you chairman um a number cunry as
a member of essex county council who are
consultees thank you
thank you very much
right we do have three
public participants this next item item
five which you will find on pages
13-23 i believe
this is looking at land north of 48
woodruff road tollsbury
so i'm going to ask for the officer
presentation please and then we'll have
the public participants and we'll move
on from there thank you
thank you chairman thank you
so just before i start my presentation
today that since the publication of the
members update um another four letters
of support have been received
they do not raise any new points of
consideration from those already
already summarized and addressed within
the offices report and the members
update
so
the site is located on the northern side
of woodruff road
outside the sediment boundary of
tullesbury the site is an open
undeveloped grassland
bounded by hedgerows to the north east
and south
the western boundary is demarcated by a
dense wooded area which separates the
field
from the
developed settlement of the village
the current proposal relates to the
construction of 29 residential
properties to provide celtic
accommodation for people over 60 years
of age
including a community hub building and
associated landscaping and
infrastructure
the development would be accessed
off of woodruff road
here
the proposed dwellings will be fronting
onto the proposed state road and the
communal garden
here
an attenuation basin is proposed along
the western boundary
the community hub is
adjacent to the
attenuation basin
and
this is where the woodland is and the
food path is proposed to be created here
and
also the documents submitted with the
application suggests that the proposed
development would incorporate dementia
friendly design principles
in terms of parking a total of 44
parking spaces are proposed and with
regards to outdoor amenities space all
properties would have access to verandas
or balconies
but due to the very nature of the
proposed development no private gardens
in their typical domestic form are
proposed as you can see on the plan
this plan shows the position of the
proposed affordable rent units
which are those marked in red
this is the soft landscaping overview
[Music]
and this is the tree layout overview
there is a pumping station proposed here
but
yeah this this is not shown on that plan
uh this is a closer view of the proposed
uh courtyard
uh and communal open space and these the
following are the
elevations and floor plans of the
dwellings proposed
so this is one and two
three and four which are semis
five to seven a small terrace
of bungalows
this is eight to twelve
part two story part single story
13 and 14
again a pair of semis
with
parking in between
uh this is another rule 15 to 20 um
a small block of flats two story and
then the rest is bungalows
21 and 22
23 and 24 these properties are on the
top to the north of the development
again to the north part of the
development
[Music]
another terrace and these are i think
that yeah these are the final ones
these are the elevations of the proposed
community building adjacent to the
attenuation basis in the wetland
area
these are some technical drawings the
fire tender swept path analysis
and the refuse swept path analysis
also including details of this build
displays and the proposed pedestrian
access which is
through here
these again are some technical drawings
showing the boundary
between the application side and the
adjacent dwelling to the west
some works to the boundary are proposed
to
protect from subsidy
and this is what these plants show
and these are some photographs of the
site
um
and
of the surrounding area these are
properties to the south this is the
adjacent dwelling to the west and this
is the public car park to the east
and these are some views
from
woodruff road
so the proposed development has been
assessed against the planning policies
and
it has taken into consideration all the
material planning considerations
including previous permissions and
appeals including the appeal decision in
relation to
application 21
0 75 slash outm relating to a
development involving the erection of
232 dwellings to form phase 2 of the
previously approved retirement community
in
burnham on crowds
um
yeah which was recently allowed the
proposed development is to provide
residential shelters accommodation for
older persons
the council as we know cannot
demonstrate a five-year housing land
supply and therefore the tilted balance
is engaged as such when the most
important policies of the plan are out
of date permission should be granted
unless any adverse impact of doing so
would significantly and demonstrably
outweigh the benefits when assessed
again the policies of the mbpf when
taken as a whole
the applicant states that the proposed
development would provide a 100 percent
affordable centered housing scheme for
all the persons
assessing the development against the
affordable housing criteria it is
concluded that the applicant has not
provided sufficient evidence to
demonstrate that the development would
be able to meet the criteria of
affordable housing in terms of uh the
affordable sales element which
constitutes 86.2 percent of the overall
scheme
furthermore it has not been demonstrated
that the development would be able to
provide affordable housing to meet the
needs of those that cannot be met by the
market within the district
therefore this considered the proposal
would constitute accommodation based on
aspirational lifestyle rather than
actual need
even if the necessary submissions were
able to demonstrate that the proposed
the proposal constitutes affordable
housing in accordance with the mppf and
albeit no objection is raised for the
provision of affordable housing per se
officers consider that the submitted
evidence is lacking in clarity and has
not been able to demonstrate that there
is a need of this quantum of this very
particular type of development
furthermore for a scheme to be
considered as a rural exception scheme
as this is outside settlement and be
policy compliant it would be required to
be to provide affordable housing in
accordance with a required 10-year sleep
split sorry which is 75 affordable rent
25 affordable sales and this development
does not propose as proposed does not
comply with this requirement
the development would have a detrimental
impact on the character and appearance
of the area due to the quantum of
development the layout the grain scale
and partial loss of the woodland on the
southwestern part and design of some of
the dwellings proposed
although one balance some sustainability
credentials are recognized in terms of
accessibility to local amenities and
public transport and by biodiversity net
gain it is considered that it has not
been demonstrated
and
that the
overall adverse
impact um identified would be able to be
outweighed by the benefits arising from
the proposed development
therefore the development is considered
unacceptable when assessed against the
correct test of the mppf
and contrary to policy to to the ldp and
the mppf when taken as a whole
for these reasons officers recommend
refusal of the application
for the reason stated on page 55 of the
agenda
uh just wanted to advise you that um
a letter from the applicant has been
received since the publication of the
report requesting the application to be
deferred to the next committee meeting
in order to incorporate some amendments
to the proposed development
obviously this is
councillor's gift to
decide
yeah that's all from me thank you
thank you um
okay so we'll move on to our public
speakers we'll have the the standard
order please so we uh there's no one
speaking as an objector we have a
supporter mr hope if you'd care to come
forward please
find a chair make yourself comfortable
please use the microphone following mr
hope will be mr play to the parish
parish council chairman and then
ms tidswell who will speak for the
applicant right mr hope you have
precisely two minutes and i am very
precise
please please use microphone so that the
people on the streaming can hear you and
we start timing when you start speaking
thank you
good evening and thanks for this
opportunity to speak in favor of the
proposed lewis and scott development my
name is pete hope and i'm a resident of
tolsby my wife and i live on the second
floor of woodrow park flats which is to
the east of the development
not far from the proposed development
there are 52 flats in the block many
occupied by people who are retired but
as we age the stairs will become an
issue
uk uk national office of
statistics has to make the total
population of salisbury around
2855 of that 945 people are over 60.
on that stat alone i would suggest it's
you know unrealistic to say that there's
no need for this kind of development in
tulsa
to my knowledge no significant survey
has actually been done by the council to
ascertain the housing needs of this
population tonight i speak for myself
approaching 70 and my closest friends in
the village who are both in their mid
70s they would have been here tonight in
support of the development but healthy
should prevent their attendance my
friend is trying to cope with the
effects of his dementia anxiety
depression insomnia all taking a toll on
him and his wife's life the worry of the
upkeep of the house and garden increases
that burden this development would mean
they could stay in a village close to
friends and their network of support
there isn't an appropriate alternative
for them it's as simple as that i know
of other retired people who've had to
move out of the village they too had no
options other than to move
our circumstances are less dire but as
we age we will be less mobile at best we
would be unable to afford anything
appropriate even with any realized
equity the fact we are having this
conversation shows how secured the
property market is and the seemingly
predetermined favor towards profitable
housing that doesn't reflect or
incorporate the very real needs of local
people
i i'd like to commend uh the work of
local councils and district councils uh
they put a lot of time and effort into
making our villages towns better places
to live but i sincerely urge you not to
refuse this application thank you thank
you perfectly timed i may say so
right mr plato please if you could come
forward pick a chair any chair
again you have two minutes precisely and
will start timing when you begin to
speak thank you
madam chairman councillors simon plato
chairman thomasville parish council and
toldsbury neighbourhood plan group and
found a member of tulsary climate change
partnership which is a new community
benevolence society with over a hundred
members the parish council view is that
this proposed development on this site
to the western edge outside the
settlement bound and boundary is
strategically wrong
we believe that the maritime element of
the village has not been fully addressed
in this application in particular we
have considerable concern at the
position of the site and the potential
and its potential significance of tidal
flooding
during the course of the planning
process last october
the environment agency issued new
guidelines estimating that sea level
will rise due to due to climate change
to a minimum of 1.2 metres at least by
2125 and will continue to rise the eea
have also addressed the increasing
frequency of tidal surges they have
publicly announced that the 1 in 100
c event is becoming an annual event and
the prediction relates to the next 30
year period
we in tulsa now monitor all unusual tide
events and the last one being on the
21st of february search surgical tides
are more frequent and and the tide is
becoming higher we can also understand
that there will be a breach sooner or
later
given the above
goldsby parish council think it would be
extremely reckless to ignore the
information considering the projected
lifespan of these units 60 to 100 years
finally we would fully support the
officers report which is detailed
comprehensive and robust and ask the
councillors to follow the office's
recommendations i'm sorry thank you
another perfect timing thank you mr
president
and last but not least miss sidswell who
is speaking for the company the
applicant company
again same for you two minutes precisely
from when you start to speak
uh hello everyone i'm helen tidwell i'm
one of the founders of lewis and scott
first and foremost i'd like to say that
we are a purpose-led organization
there is a critical shortage of
affordable homes for older people as mr
hope has said it's a national problem
but it's particularly acute in malden
there's a rapidly aging population and
there have been no affordable homes
built in the district since they were
made a priority in 2017 not for older
people
people are living in properties that are
unsafe hard to manage and expensive to
heat for the majority the prospect of
downsizing is not realistic what is
available is too expensive is too far
away forcing people to choose between
their health and staying close to their
friends and their family
we started the company based on our own
experience of trying to help family
members to downsize it was very very
difficult our approach is very very
simple we design and build homes that
are local affordable and beautiful set
in four acres of gardens salt meadows
was designed with in partnership with
university of stirling they're a world
leading expert in dimension design which
encompasses everything leading up to
dementia that's loss of sight mobility
hearing
these homes will help people to remain
independent for longer and it will
protect their long-term health and we're
ready to build now
there are no technical objections to the
site including flooding it has a clean
bill of health on every single aspect it
was approved for older persons housing
in the recent call for sites and it is
100 affordable according to the
definition of the nppf now you know my
objections to the report
i've shared that i'm not going to go
back to that
what you will also know through the
update is we've increased our offer to
nine affordable rent units which just
takes us above the 40 threshold so it's
now affordable no matter how you view it
it's not a rural exception scheme
this has been a labor of love we ask you
to think about people in need
there's an opportunity here to do
something you'll put malden on the map
it needs to happen it needs to happen
now people are depending on you thank
you
right members well we have been asked to
defer um
i'm not entirely sure
what we would gain by that sorry
councillor morley could you possibly
turn that microphone off behind you or
councillor white thank you anybody
anybody
so i'm actually going to ask
mr lee what would change what could
potentially change significantly between
now and next time given that we've been
provided with a lot of the information
um
thank you chairman um
obviously the applicant i know i think
probably a lot members have seen a lot
of correspondence about this as you know
has raised a number of concerns in
relation to the report some of which
it's just statements of they don't know
there's concerns without any real detail
um obviously they're pointing around
like huntsman affordable and the
definition npr has obviously drilled
into a lot of detail in the office
report where it explains that the
value they're coming up with in the
suggested production is about marketing
doesn't take into account the natural
reduction that there is in older
people's housing et cetera um
i think the big issue isn't as much
strongly spent a long time doing a
presentation so i will try and deal this
very quickly because no one needs to
hear my voice more than they have to but
the point is that you know the council
considers that there is harm or the lpa
does in the in relation to the character
and appearance of the area and then it
comes down to the balance and exercise
that members are fully aware of you know
accords with event plans material
consideration indicate otherwise
we haven't got a five-year land supply
so it brings in the tilted balance and
taking into account the concerns and
lack of evidence
um
some of the uh
issues we've got you know the lpa has
come to recommendation that the pro
development due to the impact on the
character of the area want a better
phrase
the harm does significantly outweigh the
benefits
in relation to a deferral um
obviously
the applicant has stated very late in
the day they would increase potentially
increased units to nine um while that
would make it policy compliant with a
better phrase in relation to the
traditional element of affordable
housing
it wouldn't overcome the lpa's concerns
in relation to the
other percentage which is their deposit
which they're trying to argue affordable
where you know we have concerns that
whether actually in the big picture does
meet the definition
also doesn't see evidence that there is
back up the argument that there is the
need for this very specific type of
offer um there's a lot of quite high
level statements um
and you know the person support the uh i
think mr hope stated you know we haven't
got a report that says what housing
specifically is needed for
tollsbs for the district and the point
is that it's the applicant's gift to
persuade us with that there is a
material situation that means we should
go against our policy
and bases as some testosterone paul
explains you know we've looked at the
evidence to fight and we don't consider
it gives us a level of uh comfort that
there is um
we've got very little
evidence about what they would be
looking to change apart from that one
figure you know we've had long
conversations about the quantum of
development the way it sits and relates
in the site and while there's been some
minor changes have been very limited in
the applicant
has been
shown limited evidence of willing to
move on that so um
i
am unclear on what would significantly
change if members were to defer it and
seek amendments
as in what those members would and how
that would change the officer's
recommendation um
you know we there is no requirement for
us to defer an application there is no
requirement for us to accept amendments
but when it comes to deferral it's been
in the gift of members so i'll pass it
back to you thank you chairman thank you
right i've got three members who wish to
speak so um
i will open the discussion now invite
you to put any questions or make any
comments you have on the report
including anything about this potential
deferral which we can bring forward at
any time but it has to be before we put
any other proposal on the table really
um so i have councillors durham fleming
keys
stevens
and morgan oh and morley
um
i've been rather moving away from that
since we're all here to represent the
whole district and besides councillor
stevens might want to hear what
everybody hates the concept
and she's fully armed so um i did catch
council darren caught my eye first so
we'll go with him council darrell
thank you chairman it's nice and i
caught your eye um chairman um
just
putting the the request for a deferral
aside because i'm dubious actually
whether that is going to achieve
anything
can i ask mr mr lee
ignoring the discrepancy with the
affordable housing element and the
unsubstantiated need
if that was clarified
to our satisfaction that it was fully
policy compliant etc etc
given our very precarious five-year land
supply or lack of that would the tilted
balance make it much more in favor
i'm just mindful of our appeal record
which is pretty was not not great at the
moment and whether the tilted balance
if all those other elements were tidied
up
would make a substantial difference and
in terms of the demand i think that the
the thing that we should take into
account is
as each year goes by and the population
ages the demand is going to rise
exponentially so taking
the need and demand now is not
necessarily
as relevant as it might be in five or
ten years or twenty years time that's a
comment
i think there's a couple of points in
relation to that um obviously it hasn't
been assessed if this was you know 100
affordable scheme in traditional terms
or if we were to consider that it was
that evidence
but you know this is quite a obviously
throwback slightly as members aware uh
outline permission for i think
24 units was granted at appeal
a subsequent application for
that development was submitted and um
refused by the committee and an appeal
was dismissed um partly in relation to
the coverage of the site and as you can
see obviously it's quite a large amount
the site isn't being built on this
actually
adds a level of development above this
as in its 29 units and once again it's
quite a concentrated intense development
so the actual impact on the character
the area
um is considered to be significant and i
think if you can go back to the
presentation you know
the actual location of the way the
layout is sorry if the demand you've got
there
you know as you can see there it
personally my professional opinion now
it sits poorly with the wider area
doesn't really need to relate to it um
it is the tilted balance um you know
it starts in favor of the uh
applicant for one of a better phrase in
favour of development um that does not
mean we should be approving everything
you know um
you know
sounds difficult we if you were to look
at it purely on numbers we actually have
quite a good success rate for dwellings
even though we haven't got a
five-year-old supply but it's because
it's making that informed educated
balancing process taken to count on
different material considerations
we are in significantly short full so it
is a balancing exercise
officers have come to a recommendation
based now professional opinion obviously
it's in members gift to come differently
um what only say in relation to cancer
dance final point about the numbers
one of the issues is is that if it's
going to be
affordable housing
in the hunt in the terms and the
discount sales and we're looking to put
on caps in relation to
either income that is an appropriate one
and potentially also including a
equity left
effect from sale of properties taken to
county evidence from llh which shows how
many people in fairly valuable
high-profile value properties
um how many own people own properties
across the district we don't have
evidence necessary that we actually have
a quantum of
people within the district that actually
could be able to take those properties
so while you're saying people are
getting older if there were caps on the
ability to access these properties
actually
include the people of malden because lha
shows that there's like generally a
higher percentage of ownership even if
there was a cascade system
it would end up with it
being aimed at people outside the
district and this is one of the evidence
we don't have the one of the issues we
don't consider we have the evidence feel
comfortable that we can definitely say
we'll be going to the residence of
malden going forward if an appropriate
cap that we feel comfortable is imposed
because the cap also as the report says
that the applicant is looking at we
think is a relatively generous one which
doesn't meet the
needs of people that are unable to
access the market
i'll just come back on that just one did
did you say my
but it was mixed up that there had been
a previous approval on this same site
that has
yeah
24 units but then the scheme that we
just showed between in an l-shape was
refused
but the but the principle of development
on this site has already been
established
it's that there's the permissions
expired so it's not established as in
there is an extent permission but it has
been found to be acceptable right but i
think the idea is to do that it would
not
i think you've got like when you look at
if you've got one that shows the
relationship with the whole site better
i think
you can see what it is there's a very
intense level of development when you
consider the size of the site and that's
what we're talking about is the impact
on the cancer area and if for example it
was a lower quantum of development it
had a different relationship layout it
may be a different
issue as the report says it's not the
fact that there's wants to be housed on
this side they're objecting to what
we're objecting to is the specifics of
this quantum development it's layout
this impact on the character of the area
which is the harm
previously yep
the site has been agreed as being
acceptable in terms of sustainability
flood risk et cetera et cetera yeah
correct so that's it that's it look for
29 was yeah thank you
right councillor
what's next thank you chad uh yep thank
you that's just what i was looking for
was the planning history for the site it
was sort of missing i thought that i'd
just couldn't find it so that's quite
helpful to know that um
so i just wanted to ask about the
pumping station just to be clear is that
bull what sort of flows is that for
sewage grey waste
we we don't have the details so that we
know that there is one potentially that
is going to be located within the site
there is going to be a need but the full
details of that have not been submitted
or surface water pumping section yeah it
would be sure yeah
for surface water okay good um
and then you referenced evidence what
can you give us an example i know this
is quite difficult to answer of what
you know what the applicant could have
provided in terms of evidence
i can determine i can i can only say
what us officers we have had in terms of
like the evidence of the council to rely
on
so we
we have the
local housing needs assessment to rely
on this is the latest document that
shows the need in terms of housing
um
the
technically i mean obviously i'm not an
expert on that but um what we would
expect it would be
an assessment of given that they target
the tullesbury village it would be
a survey
well
solsbury village to confirm
but then
but then it's hard because
there is this difference between demand
and need
as an authority we have identified
through our ldp what our need is in
terms of housing and in terms of
affordable housing
in demand is not the same is more like
what people would want that doesn't
necessarily means that there is a need
for this particular thing so it's
yeah but again it's not for us it's the
the onus of proof is is we the applicant
to demonstrate that yeah
just a little bit further on that you
know there's a lot of i would say from
about phrase assumptions of high level
you know
data and then just extrapolating that
down on assumptions that if you put this
through this equation it will give you
an accurate fact where you know
you know surveys etc to actually be able
to evidence that this is correct rather
than assumptions because you know
especially as you know it does some of
it is going against what llh states and
things so yeah that's the sort of thing
that we would expect to have much more
accurate bespoke evidence for something
like this
thank you
okay thank you thank you i've got you
counsellor keith can i just ask about
parking because i can't actually see
this very clearly what does it make the
parking standards
i'm assuming
44 yeah
and again for those schemes that they
are for retirement
um accommodation
it's like on
on base um
but yeah it's bespoke so we we have to
consider how much uh the need would be
they are 44 proposed um not
away available from the side
okay thank you for that i apologize
councillor keys no you're on my next
right
personally i think it's a fantastic idea
i think i'd
certainly encourage that in
certainly my world rather than some of
the developments that we are seeing
now
could we go into it because i say it's
too highly dense but
being
that is what the older generation like
so they can see people and meet people
now plan with missions already passed on
this place
i sat in here
a couple of months ago
and the linebrook way they were talking
about the linebrook way phase 4
before they built any affordable
bungalows
how far away from that i know that's
in our five-year or lack of five-year
land supply
now would this
enhance that because they're saying
they've built all these houses at
linebrook but there is no
no affordable and no bungalows in the
first four three phases
right remember
they're all up in arms it was going to
be on the last phase
and that's not happened so we haven't
got
sorry matt gunn
um
i've got no idea to be honest chairman
questions like that you need to give us
in advance we can't yeah yeah we can't
give you questions on how delivery rates
are off the cuff unfortunately thank you
jim
well i'm convinced that's what i heard
that it was on phase four of limebrook
way before we got any bungalows
i've certainly heard it in reference to
some of north heybridge garden suburb i
know it is true that as long as we get
the total number by
the final fantasy but this can be years
and years and years ahead yeah sometimes
they're not there yet and not coming
in the current phase
living in the area all my life i know
the site well and
yeah i'm
struggling
to find why
we shouldn't be
doing this sort of thing in a lot of the
outer villages i'm really struggling but
i'm willing to put this out to my
fellow members
i'll come to you councillor white um
council stevens are you
ready to speak and then i'll work my way
around everywhere thank you i think
we're still on questions actually so i i
hear your opinion but i've got some
questions if i may comfortable
thank you
um
i'm confused about the crossing outside
the development along woodroff road so
there's something in the report about a
pavement that will be extended within
the site down towards the marina
that's fine but for people walking up to
the village there isn't a pavement on
the same side as of the road as the
development you would have to cross the
road bearing in mind that this set this
site sits between the industrial estate
and the village that does worry me that
there are huge transporters i'm not
talking about a couple of sort of
delivery bans we're talking transporters
hgvs come down that road regularly all
the time
am i right in thinking there's no
pelican crossing zebra crossing whatever
thank you yeah through you chairman um
what is proposed as you've said is
the extension of the footpath on both
sides
but at the moment there is no footpath
running along the northern side of
woodruff road there is one on the
southern part and there is a
crossing
proposed here
and
[Music]
yeah
the
only thing i can say in relation to that
is that highway authority did not object
to that in um
yeah it did not raise an objection in
terms of like
the their proposal in relation to
pedestrian crossing
sorry did you say there is a crossing do
you mean like a zebra crossing pelican
crossing something like that or just a
place where people might cross the road
yeah through yes that's basically it
yeah there's not going to be a zebra
crossing no
okay thank you so
that remains a concern to me then um
about the crossing given the target
audience for the homes um can i ask
about security
these homes won't have any private
gardens around them and the whole site
won't have a perimeter fence or gate or
whatever um
there's reference in here about or the
national planning policy framework
refers to the need to create safe spaces
and i can see something about the
applicant has been in contact with essex
police designing out crime but i'm not
really clear what suggestions have come
out of that and whether they've been
taken up by the applicant please thank
you
sorry are you telling me
um
yeah the
the proposal as as it has been submitted
does not include any
um fencing or boundary
um
surrounding it so it's it's it's gonna
be there is no there is no
um
boundary treatment per se to
make it an an exclusive
development like outside the yeah
to protect it in in a way
um
that you're suggesting yeah
okay sorry i'm not particularly saying
that there should be boundary fences i'm
just saying given that there aren't i'm
wondering what became of this essex
police designing out crime conversation
did they make any recommendations
have those recommendations been taken up
please
yes sir through terminal here they're
just just um encouraged
they can just encourage the applicant to
get in touch with them to provide advice
in terms of safety and security but
that's what it is basically
okay so it's just an encouragement but
no real statements or changes to the
design or anything like that thank you
um can i ask please about flooding um
councillor simon plato from tullesbury
parish council has uh referred to flood
risks
would you be able to make some comments
on his
on his statement please thank you
yes thank you chairman um
what i can say is that the
environment agency has responded that
the site is located within flood zone
one
so
they do not make any spoke comments
because it's not within a flood zone um
from their perspective um
we did not receive an objection from the
local fraud authority
they were satisfied with the submissions
of the applicant within their flood risk
assessment in terms of how they will
manage the
surface water
we have had concerns raised
from our
environmental health team
the specialist
who based on experience and data they
advised us that um
there are surface water issues and they
they they are aware that the site floods
so what has been agreed
um
is that the applicant has agreed if the
application was to be approved to
provide uh
within the site the attenuation basin
but also offsite
contribution
to improve the situation whether with a
flatting obviously
given that the proposal is for refusal
this cannot be secured because this
would have to be through a section 106
agreement
thank you for that i i must say that um
i mean i can see the
the official responses oh well it's in
flood zone one so that's okay but this
is the same environment agency that
couldn't find the key to our flood gate
a few years ago so um
it's a difficult one isn't it because
we've got officially what we've been
told and then what we in tullesbury know
to be happening on the ground
and quite a number of different people
around the village who know this and
have lived in tollsbury all their life
have approached me with serious concerns
about the flood risk here the last thing
we really want to be doing is building
houses that in 50 years time are
uninhabitable or that are affected
sometimes by flooding so that really
does concern me thank you
um i might have some more questions in a
minute but i'll keep quiet for a minute
could
could a deferral allow us time if
members were minded to sort out 106 what
have you
seen or not if it's not going to change
your recommendations
well we can't actually condition it but
we can delegate it yes
yeah
so
it'd be no different with uh
like any traditional major application
if you'd like to approve you'd have
heads of terms
and then it's for officers to sort out
the uh
want between nuts and bolts on the
actual uh okay so we could delegate that
okay okay thank you
um councillor morley
thank you madam chairman um
some of my questions have sort of been
answered i'd like to know the height of
sea level it is there
and although it does flood
what's
what conditions is he going to do or the
developer do to alleviate that
um i do i do like the site i think it's
a nice layout down there but the only
thing is it's quite a long way to the
doctors
quite a steep walk up the hill that's
the downside of that
and
affordable housing and for people over
60 is there a way of conditioning it
that when they come up for sale
can you
you sort of someone in their 40s or 50s
you could say no you can't have it is
that
thank you see you chairman um what would
normally be the case obviously we
condition a property with an age cap in
relation to the discount sales what
happens is you would do the season 6 106
you'd require a
marketing and you'd have the
uh percentage production so they'd be
capped so that that production is passed
on in perpetuity so it's not case the
first buyer gets a discount and from
then on you know it's yeah so it's
retained in perpetuity through the six
106. thank you
sorry i have got councilman and then
i'll come back
my question really is related to the
question of 106 agreements they were
mentioned it's there isn't one in place
at the moment is it proposed there to be
one
there is right and
one of the terms what have those terms
been
agreed yet or where are we in that in
putting that together
through you chairman yeah um the terms
uh suggested by the applicant are within
the offices report
they are
on
just let me just give you the
uh
they are on pages
44 and 45 of the of the report is under
developer developer contributions
thank you
thank you and moving on there was a very
moving
statement from i think mr um
hope regarding obviously his wish to
sort of be able to stay in the village
but i'm just wondering how are we going
to
obviously when when
that
his or anybody else's period of
occupation ends are they going to be
able to pass that on to in terms of
their will or so or how is that gonna
operate
through your chairman um
obviously if it's your property you pass
it on but um through your will etc but
it wouldn't mean you'd be able to occupy
if you were under the uh age capacity
right
and but so but would you a would you
obviously if you inherited it in that
particular way and therefore when they
were would you would you be able to
listen to something
out someone who was i
restrictions in relation to age and also
uh income right well
in terms of the income how is that how
are you going to be able to police that
what's the what's the way of being able
to support
so somebody's gonna have to produce
evidence of what they're being well
there'd need to be a mechanism likely to
in relation to who would manage the
sales of that which normally a rich
provider would deal with
or even if it's their cells sometimes
they're dealt with through a management
organization and that's that'll be
something that would be need to be
required and
yeah
confirmed through the section 106
agreement um i said you know
you would normally pick a
a figure uh
and obviously that would be
somehow agreed to increase you know
obviously of 10 years time
pension will be larger
it's been suggested is the
average for um the east of england isn't
it
i think yes
yeah and obviously that's one of the
concerns we've stayed is that that
doesn't really necessarily relate to
mulder specifically enough and also
um
does it being the average really meet
the people that need affordable housing
that's one of the concerns we've raised
as a consideration and
obviously members can
not have that concern if they don't wish
but that's one of the concerns we've had
is actually does that
figures that they're proposing meet the
people that need affordable housing
rather than people that could meet
market housing if they so wish thank you
thank you um right i've got sorry i've
got council of white who hasn't had to
go yet
and then i'll go around at the beginning
again
yeah i i have to say i'm generally in
favor of um
retirement villages and retirement homes
but as i'm looking at this plan
um in my experience of very elderly
relatives they can't walk very far and
they're not very able um am i right in
thinking there's no car parking spaces
outside every single dwelling because
it just seems a bit bizarre that it's
elderly people's housing
and and their looks like to me on the
drawing they've got to park the cars and
then walk quite some distance to their
houses that's the first
for you chairman um
some of them are provided
outside obviously the houses like these
are in relation to those but then you've
got like houses such as this one or
these here that they have under croft
parking
this this is an example i'm giving you
undercroft so basically under a roof
that's good because that raised that one
and um
with flooding if it's flood zone one it
shouldn't be flooding is there flooding
history there because it should be high
enough that it doesn't so that that's
that's one and i also think that they
they um
there really does need to be an
on-demand pedestrian crossing as
councillor stevens came up with
yeah yes sorry the thing about that is
we that's a highways matter and it's not
in their land ownership um and so you
know you can't make the applicants do
something they actually can't do no
matter how much they want to
sorry did you have something to add to
that sure you could put it back
it's it in relation to your point about
surface water is um
it's slightly different in terms of
flooding surface water aside could be
within a critical drainage
area and it could have potentially
surface water issues that doesn't
necessarily mean that it has to be
within
a flood zone floating two or three
yeah which it isn't as we've already
said
i have historically been
there has historically been a lot of
surface water flooding down there but
whether that can be solved with the
right subs i'm not an engineer i don't
know but that's the whole point of sucks
as long as they do what they're supposed
to do
um council durham you wanted well i just
really wanted to come um
partly to assist councillor morgan um my
mother-in-law lives next door at once
haven
and uh the elderly person next door died
left it to her
son
who doesn't fulfill the criteria so he's
not allowed to live in it and i'm
assuming that's the same
the same situation and again on the
parking actually next door which is
exactly the same sort of scenarios here
very few of them actually still drive um
so there's um
not a huge i think there's probably more
parking per capita there
um but as yeah i i
well okay i'll i'll keep my powder dry
on that one but that's just wanted to
make that point for the assistant
hmm
[ __ ]
so at some point there will be houses or
building on here anyway is that
roughly yeah isn't it
that's what i mean so
i do like the layout that's the that's
what i'm fighting against yeah it is it
does seem rather nice to retar i'd like
to retire there
seriously do you chairman but what i'd
say count smallies i wouldn't know if
you'd
meet the requirements for actually being
able to get a unit because you put if
you could
well no that's the point if you can
afford it you wouldn't be able to be
able to that's the point
that's the point isn't it so um
um but i'll say this um will there be
venom on this site oh i think we're
struggling
uh not to allow a form development and
it isn't as the office but we're not
objecting the principle of development
on this site it's coming down to the
quantum of develop over such a small
part of the site is really what the the
layout some concerns in relation to
certain designs yeah basis for once it's
the quantum and layout that is the
concerns with this scheme not the
principle of it is the height and then
when we come to the balance exercise
officers are recommending that the harm
significantly outweighs the benefit so
it's not the principles it's you know
quantum layout appearance etc thank you
chairman
yes council of keys
well i've got a couple of comments i
mean i accept the principle of
certainly except the prince of
development is is there and unless
something changed conditions trying to
change drastically with you know
flooding and so on and tidal and you
know
who knows but you know we are where we
are now and and i don't see why anyone
wouldn't get outline applications
permissions applied again but i i am
concerned that i am concerned about the
distance from the village and i am
concerned about the large numbers and uh
because i'm concerned about the flooding
but i'm not an engineer and it's
you know no one cares what i think
basically it's down to the
environment agency isn't it
sorry i'll just let council stephen come
back and then
if you have a proposal
we'll see if it's seconded thank you
i've probably got a few more questions
and then a whole raft of comments and
nobody will go home tonight because i've
got i've been reading and reading and
reading about this and i still feel
utterly divided i really do feel divided
but i've got some more questions
you get three minutes i know i know so
just be quick right
can i can i confirm that whilst there is
an income limit of i think it was 30 000
or 31 000 there's no capital asset limit
is that correct please through terminal
yes that's what's tested again that was
one of the concerns raised by officers
thank you so somebody could sell a two
million pound house in tullesbury and
they've got an income of 25 000. they're
over the age of 60 and they're in and
they get the discount and they pocket
the difference so that that seems a bit
strange to me
but you know they might form an orderly
queue everybody um
am i right also in thinking that we
these figures are still correct are they
that we have a surplus of 426 affordable
homes in the district and that
affordable homes should be 75 percent
rented which would not be the case here
thank you
again through youtube yes this is what
the local housing needs assessment
suggests that there is a surplus of this
type
sheltered type of accommodation
affordable
not market
and
the split to be policy compliant yes it
should be 75 rented 25
sales
right so i think that demonstrates quite
clearly that we don't need this in the
district so it's not as if
we could say well let's accept such a
dense population of houses because we
really really need this we don't so it
that does seem a great conflict to me it
is very dense
it's much denser even than the one that
was refused because of density
um and when you look at the planning
inspectors comments last time um
it was all around the density the grain
the the um
the scale and i don't think any of those
things have changed so i think that it
would get rejected for the same reasons
again at appeal if it went that far um
and last time there was no proposal to
get rid of any woodland and this time
there's plan to get rid of woodland
which seems to be even more detrimental
i'll let someone else have a go
i'd actually be happier if i'm not
saying i would necessarily support it
because i can't but i'd be happier if
there was a lot more rented and a
certain amount of just straightforward
market
it makes it that it's you know it would
have to come back as its own application
but it it would save an awful lot of
these complications
it's a thought from a non-professional
counselor keys you want if you want to
put a proposal
yeah i'd like to put a proposal that we
um
go for this probably yeah
and go against the officers
right now we need a refuge for refusal
that address that's coming for approval
address all the reasons given for
approval and we also need some
suggestions as to
that
okay
unless there's anything you had in mind
we would delegate
to officers uh ditko the 106. yeah
but if there was anything you had in
mind like
external lighting i would certainly want
that
hmm
well we haven't got a proposal until
we've got the reasons for approval it
isn't a proposal we can debate well
could i could i put a proposal forward
that we defer it and see if they can get
some of the issues raised by officers um
in relation to rented or market value or
anything else could we defer it for
another month i'd be have to put forward
that proposal that we defer it and see
if we can get something more acceptable
i'll second it then
i'll second that then
um well yes that's a proposal anyone
second council of whites
okay
um
well let's put that to the vote that's
the first motion we've actually got on
the table so those in favor of deferral
for further
further
communication with the officers and and
whatever is required in the way
changes those in favor
uh anyone against deferral
okay
so um
we have deferred did you get the numbers
all right on that spurred
any other items of business that the
chairman decides are urgent you'll be
grateful to hear there aren't any so i
closed the meeting with thanks to all
all officers all members and all members
of the public and
uncle tom cobley and all i closed the
meeting at 8 31. well done